we're still three weeks away from
setting our clocks back for the end of
daylight saving time but as CBS News
Congressional correspondent Scott
McFarland reports setting our clocks
ahead and back every few months could
soon be a thing of the past if some
lawmakers have their way for Jen Shafer
a high school teacher raising her
energetic twin 22 month old daughters
Leela and Willa
there are two other precious Commodities
time and sleep see where is she at when
you see Daylight Saving coming on the
calendar
you excited or do you dread it oh I
dread it it's definitely going to throw
a curveball at us and
it's going to mess us up for the next
few days even a week the twice a year
changing of the clock springing forward
for Daylight Saving Time for spring
summer and early fall spread in the U.S
during World War One to conserve energy
for the war effort
was stretched even later into November
nearly 15 years ago as part of an energy
saving bill championed by Michigan
Congressman Fred Upton particularly with
global warming climate change it's real
why not take advantage of that extra
hour of sunlight this is something that
should be bipartisan Congress put
Daylight Saving back in the spotlight
this year in a formal hearing the house
energy committee heard testimony the
clock changing is linked to increased
risk of depression stroke and sleep
disruption and not just for sleepy mobs
of young twins says Children's National
Hospital Sleep expert Dr tyish Hall
Brown we have an internal kind of Rhythm
to our our body into our health and
every time we move forward or backwards
that has to adjust as well and making
people aware of the harm that clock
switching has in March without warning
the U.S Senate by unanimous consent
passed legislation to make Daylight
Saving permitted as of 2023 and to put a
halt to the clock changing at the U.S
house and the president agreed but
Congressman Upton says the effort will
likely come up short in the house partly
because some are concerned in the
western section of time zones permanent
Daylight Saving could make for some very
dark late mornings those school buses
would be running in the dark if we
didn't change the clocks Not only would
they be running in the dark the kids
probably would be in second or third
hour while it was still
it's for Jen Schaefer time change or not
rest will always be a little bit more
elusive it's just a huge learning curve
and when you think you know something
when you think you have it figured out
of course then they hit that next
Milestone or that next stage and we have
to relearn it all were you running off
to with less than three months remaining
in this Congress supporters of this idea
to make Daylight Saving Time permanent
running out of time
for CBS Saturday morning I'm Scott
McFarland at the Capitol
my only thing with the going to school
in the dark I know that Jack goes to
school so early now that's going to
happen practically anyway yeah so what
difference does that mean yeah I say
hold on to our Traditions we're losing
so many of them
and all that stuff do it wow that's
awesome are you with me I'm like so yeah
I understand some of the issues we'll
fight
overall yeah might happen you need to
you need to like punch across the table
and not just like do this thing well